all right now I'm giving you a big
number and this is not in your textbooks
this is not something that your obably
in your testing on but it's really cool
so it's new to pay attention okay now
264 in a second we're going to do
something with this that you know how to
do but first I'm going to ask you a
question
and see what you can do with it okay
don't make any comment yet just think
about it in here can you work out if I
want to multiply by this by some number
and get a square number at the end
multiply it by something and I get some
square okay I don't know what the square
would be but I assume it'd be quite
large my question is what is the very
smallest number I can pick that will do
that I mean obviously I could multiply
by 264 and that would give me a square
wouldn't it and it would be enormous
okay but surely I can multiply by a
smaller number than 264 and get a square
now my question is how do I do that
that's a question mark nothing all right
now here's the one we're gonna approach
it okay we're gonna take this coup you
already know and then I'm going to try
to show you how you can use it to get is
okay let's cool you've already been
showing me just now is prime
factorization can we do it yeah what do
you want / now you could do to like come
on come on let's be a bit quicker surely
we can do four surely all right we might
even be able to a bigger one than that
but that's before now Shh think about it
think about it I'm gonna picture as I
know you can use your calculator but we
try to work this thing okay right so I
see 200 and then I see 64 you guys can
do 200 divided by 4 surely it's 50 isn't
it okay
so that's 200 now 164 how many fours is
64
there are 16 is 16 okay these are
numbers which you should be able to
rattle off particularly the quicker ones
of you so I get 15 out of 16 so that
makes it 66 okay
you see that's much better than doing /
- that's much slower yeah what's the
factorization here Georgie what we have
here now what - okay so let's complete
our factor tree I'll bring the 11 down
I'll bring these two down okay so I've
got 2 times 2 times 11 times 2 times 3
what was my number 264 so how can I
write this in index form so it's been
neat to for us this will be yeah
excellent
ok whoa what happened there okay all
right now watch here's where the magic
is now what do I want
I want a square number or some kind ok
square number I want to multiply this by
some square number now come back this is
one of the useful things of having this
board I wish I had this all the time
okay a hundred this is a square number
and you already knew that
okay but pay attention to its prime
factorization right
can you see since 100 is squared right
watch all the prime factors also have to
be squared
you see that right when you wait up to
UM or here you have 24 which is not
square right so it's prime factorization
it's enough squares in it okay but this
one does it has to right because if you
take each one independently you get your
10 and your 10 and that's why it's a
square number 100 now come down to here
if I want to make this into a square
right another hole
all of my prime factors will have to be
squared this make sense
so for instance this 3 right it's
mucking up my number it's not going to
give me a square so I need to multiply
by 3 then this will become 3 square
it'll be it'll give me a square same
thing here the 11 is mucking it up right
so if I multiply by another one then
I'll have 11 square now but one last
thing to do it is 2 cubed what's too
cute as a number what is equal to 2
cubed Hey
it's 2 times 2 times 2 which is 8 is 8
squared yes it's not square and you can
see because this is a 3 I want like a 2
right hmm now I cut I can't divide by
numbers I want to multiply by something
to get a square right so instead I'm
going to multiply by the switch see
what's gonna happen
8 times 2 what's that 16 and 16 is a
square not sure so what I wanna multiply
by if I multiply by 2 and 3 and 11 all
at once 1 by multiplying by 2 times 3 is
6 6 times 11 is so it's 66 that's what I
want to multiply by okay so let's try it
in theory I'm saying that should give us
a square by the way 364 times 66 it's
still gonna be a big Monomoy work it out
go ahead and work it out get on your
calculator what is it
17000 424 okay now one of the cool
things about calculator is it has a
square root button on it what you want
what's it equal to is it a square number
what do you get
what do you get square root of seventeen
thousand four hundred twenty-four is 132
it worked